julia ça va le salut
salut
et mais ça reste étroite
elle semblait pourtant dans la maison
c'est bien ces censeurs nous titille
quand même mois mais j'y connais rien à
la photographie mais elle recense au
courant comme elle à la hauteur en fait
je m'intéresse beaucoup à l'aviation
d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien tomber si tu
voudrais vivre c'est grave
c'est mon rêve depuis tout petit hier je
vous ai rien dit oui à prendre déjà
pourra monter parce que c'est pas le
point fort de vie mais c'est pas une
raison ah ouais et c'est quoi exactement
[Musique]
move alors comment alors
pour un culte non pas des volants dans
les avions c'est même en chanel et
balises à lyon et pour les hommes et
donc j'avais avec lui pour les filles
vous dites n'importe quoi à wichita que
tu as toi bah oui mme amara sy qui est
la dinde ou aux bonnes personnes qui
veut sauver des vies cette inutile marie
marvingt seen pionnier de l'aviation et
en plus de ça une grande roue air bien à
la première guerre mondiale l alice
faire passer pour 1 heure pendant 47
jours près des poilus pour pouvoir aller
au fond c'est évidemment une grande
sportive est aussi la première fois -
fini le tour de fonds et pour couronner
le tout elle a réussi à trouver une
nouvelle manière efficace de suturer la
plaie des blessés bon allez vous vous
réveillez vos consommations
beaucoup payent la prochaine fois j'ai
pas si on a besoin c'est pas quasi par
contre on peut tout en voile et arrangez
vous pour y aller dans le bar a bien sûr
connaissons c'est sympa pour ce soir
quoi tu plaisantes la wipo et je passais
pas chez moi amusez-vous à qui n'est pas
des plus faciles que depuis le canadien
et pour vous abonner il suffit de suivre
la poussière